we talked about uh the links between
physics and computing in different
contexts like things like reversible
computing a little bit the ultimate
limits of computing did a little bit of
neuromorphic computing and things like
that what we haven't touched on which
would seem to be the obvious one for
physicists is quantum computing the
thing that
is always
described as sort of the most mystical
element of quantum mechanics and it it
irritates computer scientists
and it irritates physicists there's a
guy called scott aaronson from a
computer science perspective he really
demolishes this myth well the way
quantum computing works is you basically
set up your system and the the the
quantum bit can be in any possible state
in all these different parallel
universes and basically because you're
trying all the answers in parallel
that means you can pull out the right
answer
that's
rubbish rubbish
there's an awful lot of hype
about quantum computing that doesn't
mean that the science and the
mathematics and the physics isn't valid
it very much is obviously i'm not going
to be able to explain the entirety of
quantum computing in 10 minutes you're
not going to get this is exactly how it
works in any 10-minute video
but what i really do want to get to the
the core of is something called
superposition and that's this is the
thing where almost everything starts to
go wrong in terms of descriptions of
what's going on with quantum computing
in that okay we've got a classical bit
that can be zero one then the argument
is well with a quantum bit it can be
some mixture zero one and therefore we
can have any possible mixture and
therefore
because we can have any possible mixture
suddenly your answer da da appears by
magic
and it really does seem to magic
superposition
um this idea of something being in two
states at the same time always dressed
up as this weird isn't it really isn't
there are two approaches to broad
approaches to quantum mechanics there's
something called matrix mechanics which
computer scientists love obviously
because it's got matrices and vectors
and it's easy to set up on a computer
and it's easy to um
to think about lists of numbers and how
those interact and how you change those
however equivalently and it is
completely equivalently we have
something called wave mechanics because
ultimately
quantum mechanics is all about the
physics of waves
and
not just from a very abstract um
perspective in that we can represent
these quantities as waves here's a whole
series of different images taken with
something called a scanning tunneling
microscope in this for example this is
taken from work by ibm quite a number of
years ago more than 20 years ago at this
point they formed a ring of 48 iron
atoms that's not the good bit the good
bit is if you look inside this ring it's
as if you dropped a stone in a pond time
and time again we see these waves
matter behaves like a wave when you get
down to the atomic level which means
that all of the the classical physics
about waves and all the classical
mathematics about waves we can pour it
into quantum mechanics i'm not going to
go through each and every one of these
images but what you're seeing here each
time is how electrons behave right down
at the at the atomic level how does this
relate to superposition well
superposition is painted as this weird
quantum effect but actually
any time
you pick up a musical instrument you
pluck a string
what you have is a superposition of
waves on that string this string can be
in a range of different types variety of
different types of modes of oscillation
waves of vibrating when you pluck that
you're not just exciting one wave you're
exciting a whole load of waves together
what are those waves well monkey
which is um making his debut i think on
computer file so this is a
large scale demonstration of a guitar
string and there are special modes of
vibration
called standing waves or resonances or
if we want to use the mathematical term
and perhaps the term computer scientists
are a little bit more familiar with and
a more quantum-y term eigenstates
special states of the string of the
string
that we can build up any particular
pattern of waves on the string using
just these particular states and these
resonances
here's the lowest energy one
where we've got what's called an
anti-node in the middle maximum
vibration in the middle and nodes at the
end of each string now i'm going to try
and get the second one so i have to
wiggle a little bit more quickly as does
monkey there we go
okay so that's our second mode that's
our second special motive and get it
right
i'm blaming the monkey so second special
mode or second resonance or second
standing wave or second harmonic or
second eigenstate all those
oh that was close
what have you done
right he's got a malicious look and he's
he has he definitely does
i think that's the third mode
right
so i have to pump in quite a bit more
energy for that one and i'd have to pump
in more energy there's a whole series of
these here's our um
two points where it was fixed so i was
one end monkey was the other end our
first mode looked like that
our second mode of vibration looked like
that
our third motor vibration
looked like that and i ran out of steam
at that point but there's a whole host
of these
all the way up um in terms of different
resonances and the thing that connects
all these they're the same type of
function it's a sine function
and in terms of the physics of the
problem what when we write down the
equation that describes this our
solutions or signs and what are what are
called our boundary conditions are that
it just needs to go to zero here and
here there's an infinite number of these
solutions that work on the string i
don't have infinite energy
so i can't excite all of these
but what we can have and this is key
when it comes to superposition and
quantum mechanics is we're not
restricted to these of course a string
doesn't just vibrate like this or this
or this
if i pick up the base
and plug the string
it'll turn around
so this is the first mode plus the
second mode plus the third mode plus the
fourth etc etc if sean were to pick up
his guitar and play a
an e note on guitar um exactly the same
e note so if we looked at it in musical
notation it would sound different or
better if sean were to play it on on
piano it would be the same note
exactly the same note in terms of a
treble clef in terms of musical notation
but it would sound different and the
reason it sounds different is because we
have a different superposition of those
resonances if i play an e note on bass
you play an enorm piano can you tell the
difference well yeah you know you know
that you can just hear the different
instruments right yeah you can hear the
different instruments it's the same note
but you can hear the different
instruments the reason you can hear the
different instruments is a lot of
although it's the same note therefore is
the same frequency therefore repeats
with the same period in time
the pattern the overall pattern is
different and the reason the overall
pattern is different or the overall
waveform is different is because you
have a different mixture of these
harmonics on the string
so
the each instrument has its own
signature mixture of those particular
states on the string
eigenstates on the string and therefore
you have a different superposition
and in terms of quantum computing it's
all about controlling how those
different
states on the string in this case
interfere with each other
and
you let the system evolve so you pluck
your string you wait for a certain
amount of time for those waves to
interfere with each other and then you
make a measurement to pull out the the
overall answer that is not at all the
same as saying that what we do is we
have an infinite number of answers and
we pull out you know we just let it run
and as if by magic we pull out an answer
what we have to do is very very and when
i say i
i'm not involved in developing these
algorithms so people who develop these
algorithms have to think very carefully
how do we engineer those waves how do we
engineer those states to interfere with
each other so at the end when we make a
measurement out pops the result we want
so superposition in that sense is just
classical physics it's been physics that
we've known about for two or three
hundred years of course that's not all
there is to quantum the issue of course
is when we um make a measurement of our
quantum system so for example imagine
this is our measuring instrument and i
plug that base string
okay we're going to measure what the b
string is doing
and we hear it quantum mechanically
that's not what happens quantum
mechanically we plug this string or we
set up this quantum state this um
superposition state when we then make a
measurement
if we make it want to know the energy of
of the string what happens is that it
falls into one of these states
with a certain probability
why
if you know that you get a nobel prize
that's the confusion thing not
superposition per se because
superposition you know is is there in
classical physics it's the question of
just why when we make a measurement it's
even called the measurement problem in
physics so we can take our um guitar
string and we can port it all the way
down to the quantum level it's it's
amazing this is a paper published by a
stefan fralsch's group in berlin this is
absolutely beautiful work they've taken
indian atoms and they formed a line of
indium atoms which acts as a string
basically along which the electrons can
can move
and the red bits represent where there's
a high probability of finding electrons
and the darker bits as you can see
represent where there's a low
probability of finding electrons and
it's exactly the same as we just was we
saw on the guitar string low at the ends
high in the middle then when i vibrated
monkey a little bit faster we had um low
peak
then we had a minimum then a maximum
then a minimum
just as i've drawn on the on on the
paper
this is right at the quantum level so
this is why physicists often get very
frustrated when quantum mechanics is
painted as this incredibly mystical um
very
weird wacky
it is it has its elements but an awful
lot of it is very very understandable
using physics and maths that we've known
for a very long time
so where does this go in terms of
quantum computing well what we could do
is let's say we're going to use the
first mode of our quantum string
a zero and the second mode of our
quantum string is one
so what we can do is we can have a
mixture a superposition
of our zero and one states
as a qubit
as a quantum bit so it's not just zero
or one it can be a mixture of zero and
one so what we have
is this and this and we have some
mixture we have some superposition
of just those two states
right so we could have ten percent of
this and
ninety percent of this or fifty percent
etcetera or forty seven percent one
fifty three percent of the other what
i've done here is set up a very simple
simulation which basically
simulates a quantum string in that we've
got our zero and our one states in terms
of the the lowest mode and the next high
next lowest mode just so just as i
demonstrated with the monkey the first
one and the second one
they can be our zero and one in terms of
a quantum bit and we can have a mixture
of those so that's what we have we have
50 mixture of each of those and here's
how it evolves in time
this is telling us how our probability
the brighter it is the higher the
probability of finding the particle
there
this is a quantum particle
and this tells us about the probability
so the wave is telling us about the
probability of finding a particle you
can see it's just basically an intensity
map of this
all of that is is pure classical physics
here's where it gets strange if we now
make a measurement and we try to well
let's see
let's make a measurement of the energy
of this this string this this state if
we do that
that's what happens and it collapses
into that state so it stops making the
noise and it also starts making a noise
because is that oscillating sean
no that's what we call a stationary
state
and we've dropped the system into that
state that's weird
that's really weird moreover that's if
we make a measurement of energy if we
make a measurement safe position
all hell breaks loose
so let me slow this down as well so this
will make more sense to you
so we'll reset it we'll run it
and now if i measure position and slow
it all the way down so you can see how
it evolves just what's happening
right so that's it
so now we've measured we found our
particle is here but that's just a ton
of waves
if we now let the system of i've i've
stopped it in time now i'm going to let
it just move forward in time
and all those waves are spreading out
which is what would happen on a string
as well the the waves you know if you
pluck it here obviously the waves travel
that way they travel that way
and they hit the ends of the the string
they hit the walls they bounce back
and all those different modes are now
interfering with each other we speed it
up
we get all those different modes all
interacting with each other now we've
got a superposition of very many states
but now again if we decide we're going
to measure the energy
bang it collapses into one state with a
certain probability and we know the
maths
in terms of how to work out what the
probability of it going into that state
or a different state is
the difficulty is we don't know why it
does that
when we make a measurement of position
what we do is we we find that what we're
doing is saying that well because we've
now made a measurement of the position
we know that the particle is in a
certain region of space
but that is just another wave
that's just like when you pluck a string
imagine plucking a string localized
little point so that means that is the
sum of that
plus that plus that
plus
that plus
etc etc etc so what we now have is this
plethora of different modes vibrating
and that's when you get this mess
and then you know this is why if you
think of it in terms of waves
quantum mechanics is i wouldn't say it's
simple
but
it makes a hell of a lot more sense than
you if you think of it like this because
if you ask yourself i've got a particle
in a box which is what we're
representing with this and you ask what
its trajectory is look at that if i were
to say how is it moving it's very very
difficult because you've got all these
different waves interfering quantum
mechanics is fundamentally about waves
hence wave mechanics
and this superposition idea although
it's really complicated to understand in
terms of objects like that which are
classical objects we're interested in if
we think of it in terms of waves it
makes a hell of a lot more sense
if we just scroll forward in time we can
see that as things start to happen we
get to this point where
everything starts to reroute and rather
than going directly to facebook you can
start to see
all this w this is some actual cipher
text that we'll be breaking later does
it honestly start with zoos as in
conrad's use
the reality of random